liebe kolleginnen und kollegen herzlich
willkommen in der bundespressekonferenz
zu dieser mittlerweile fast schon
traditionellen pressekonferenz mit
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn am
freitag
es ist wieder dabei professor doktor
lothar wieler der präsident des robert
koch instituts und heute auch der
minister für arbeit gesundheit und
soziales des landes nordrhein westfalen
karl josef laumann herzlich willkommen
an unsere gäste an diesem morgen bevor
wir einsteigen ein paar kurze sätze
meinerseits
sie sehen eine pressekonferenz dieses
vereins der bundespressekonferenz wir
sind eine selbstorganisation den oder
listen und journalisten die hier in
berlin über die bundespolitik berichten
wir veranstalten hier die regelmäßig
pressekonferenzen und gewährleisten dass
die mitglieder dieses vereins und die
mitglieder des vereins der ausländischen
presse ihre fragen hier loswerden
unter corona bedingungen an sonst nicht
aber jetzt in diesen zeiten
gewährleisten wir auch dass es einen
live stream gibt unter anderem auf
phoenix wir werden der begleiteten
gebärdendolmetscher meinen dank an
phoenix und auch ein willkommen an die
dolmetscher sie begrenzen diese
pressekonferenz aus cologne ergründen
auf roundabout eine stunde
deswegen würde ich sie bitten sich auf
eine frage gegebenenfalls eine nachfrage
zu begrenzen
im zweifel wenn die zeit nehme ich sie
noch mal mit auf die liste so viel von
meiner seite' und wir beginnen und
übergibt das wort an sie herr sprachen
der liebe frau wolff meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren der professor villa
wird gleich erneut eine lage beschreiben
müssen die wir alle längst gerne hinter
uns gelassen hätten
die lage ist dass die inzidenz zahlen
stagnieren oder solar sogar leicht
steigen
dass sich die virusvarianten weiter
ausbreiten
dass sich wieder mehr menschen mit dem
virus anstecken
das ist leider wieder realität trotzdem
haben die ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten zusammen mit der
bundesregierung vorgestern vorsichtige
lockerungsschritte beschlossen
wie passt das zusammen
es ist das ringen darum die richtige
balance zu finden eine balance zwischen
dem bedürfnis von uns allen nach mehr
normalität und der notwendigkeit
gleichzeitig uns vor gesundheitsgefahren
zu schützen
wir gehen damit an die grenzen dessen
was aus gesichtspunkten des
gesundheitsschutzes verantwortbar ist
gleichzeitig ist nach monaten des lok
downs klar keine öffnung schritte zu
wagen war auch kaum verantwortbar wir
gerne auch aus angesichts der aktuellen
diskussion kurz was zu schnell und
selbst test sagen
wichtig ist aus meiner sicht beides
auseinanderzuhalten in der diskussion
die schnelltests sind das was wir seit
september oktober kennen die du in der
regel durch dritte oder eine
nachschulung bei einem selbst
durchgeführt werden die nicht frei
verfügbar sind und die tatsächlich
sicher auch in vielen stellen in
pflegeeinrichtungen gesundheitswesen in
den schulen auch schon ein stück in den
alltag eingespielt haben die selbsttests
oder eigenen tests sind das was es neues
gibt zugelassen seid jetzt etwa zwei-
oder eineinhalb wochen und die jetzt
verfügbare werden auch hier angekündigt
über das wochenende in den ersten im
einzelhandel erstmals verfügbar sein
werden und die man eben an sich selbst
durchführen kann aber das sind zwei
verschiedene kategorien zu den
schnelltests die im alltag zusätzlich
sicherheit geben können ab montag
finanziert der bund für alle bürgerinnen
und bürger mindestens einmal pro woche
einen solchen test ein bürger test
es ist vorgesehen dass das in den
lokalen testzentren vor ort passieren
kann wenn die kommune vor ort das
organisiert in einem eigenen testzentrum
zusammen mit kooperationspartnern
dritten mit apotheken oder anderen so
wie es ja auch vielfach schon gelebt
wird in böblingen in tübingen in
schmalkalden in rostock viele kommunen
zeigen ja schon seit vielen wochen wie
es eben pragmatisch vor ort angepasst
auf die situation möglich ist dieses
angebot zu machen
der wichtige unterschied ist der bund
übernimmt nun die kosten dafür und
ermöglicht es damit noch mehr
dieses angebot zu machen es wird nicht
überall gleich
am 8 märz verfügbar sein das haben die
bundesländer schon gesagt aber viele
bundesländer haben ihm auch gesagt dass
sie anfang nächster woche tatsächlich
auch loslegen werden das entscheidende
ist der bund setzt den rahmen übernimmt
die kosten und macht es damit eben
möglich dass jetzt und ich bin sehr
zuversichtlich dass das jetzt auch zügig
vor ort umgesetzt werden kann so die
bedingungen sind mit der test verordnung
die wir noch in der nacht der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz in die
abstimmung gegeben haben damit eben auch
das rahmenwerk das rechtliche klar ist
dass mit der test vor um die grundlage
da ist von diesem schnelltests sind mehr
als genug da sind verfügbar sind einfach
bestellbar und jedes dieser testzentren
das beauftragt wird weiß auch wo es sie
bestellen muss es passiert jeden tag in
deutschland zig millionen tests sind
verfügbar
die hersteller sagen uns dass ihre lager
voll sind selbsttests kommen wie gesagt
auch der dann in den einzelhandel jetzt
nach und nach wir haben im moment sieben
zugelassene hersteller weitere werden
folgen
ich habe jetzt gestern noch in einigen
telefonaten von einigen herstellern
gesagt bekommen sie schaffen sogar 20
millionen tests pro woche selbst tests
zu liefern
mit 20 millionen selbst setzt pro woche
könnte man jeden schüler in deutschland
zwei mal pro woche testen oder gegen das
möglich machen mit einem selbsttest auch
da ist das angebot sehr zügig hoch
gerade und ich biete mich und das werde
ich am wochenende machen ich biete mich
auch als kontaktbörse an sozusagen
ministerielle kontaktbörse vergeben
ministerpräsidenten anbieten
ein kontakt zu den herstellern direkt zu
vermitteln damit für die schulen und
kitas bestellt werden kann
und ich möchte dann aber nicht in sechs
monaten lesen warum hat der minister
selbst telefoniert um das allerdings
auch klar zu sagen der bürger test und
der selbst test bietet keine absolute
sicherheit
wer positiv getestet wird sollte direkt
sein ergebnis mit einem pcr test
überprüfen lassen
und wer negativ getestet wird sollte
sich nicht
in falscher sicherheit wiegen es bleibt
weiterhin wichtig auf abstand hygiene
medizinische schutzmaske zu tragen
gut zum impfen zeug das etwas länger
wird mir war wichtig bei den tests das
einfach mal einzuordnen auch was das
angebot angeht und die unterschiede und
die möglichkeit auch eben zu bestellen
impfen es kommt mehr und mehr impfstoff
klar ist der impfstoff ist da muss
schnell verimpft werden
die länder haben angekündigt ihre
kapazitäten rasch hochzufahren
das ist entscheidend für unser tempo
trotzdem wird in den nächsten wochen
spätestens im laufe des aprils mehr
impfstoff da sein als in den impfzentren
und durch mobile impft imst verimpft
werden kann dann im april
das haben wir auch beschlossen auf der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit der
bundesregierung sollen die arztpraxen
routinemäßig mit einbezogen werden in
die impfungen viele bundesländer machen
das jetzt im übergang schon auch in
modellprojekten und der beauftragung
aber dann routinemäßigen was ist der
unterschied bei routinemäßig dann wird
der bund direkt an den großhandel
liefern
der großhandel der ja zwei bis drei mal
am tag teilweise fünfmal heute schon an
die apotheken an fährt wird das direkt
weiter verteilen an die apotheken und
die apotheken werden ist dann jeder
apotheke hat im schnitt 34 arztpraxen
für die sie auch heute schon den
sprechstundenbedarf organisieren in die
arztpraxen bringen das wird innerhalb
von bis zu 24 stunden möglich sein und
liefert da und 24 stunden später sind
die impfstoffe in den arztpraxen
vereinbar mit einer logistik die ja
heute schon steht grippeimpfstoffe
kommen auf den gleichen weg über die
apotheken zum beispiel in die arztpraxen
dafür haben wir den rahmen besprochen
auch mit allen beteiligten und werden
ihn jetzt am montag nochmal mit den
ländern karl-josef besprechen in einer
gemeinsamen schalte und dann gemeinsam
den punkt definieren wo wir diesen
schritt auch bei genug impfstoff wird da
sind dann haben miteinander gehen können
also testen impfen vorsicht dieser
dreiklang wird in den nächsten wochen
besonders wichtig seien
es geht darum
freiheit zurück zu gewinnen und
gleichzeitig das erreichte nicht zu
verspielen
die beschlossene bremse für die
lockerungsschritte halte ich deshalb für
wichtig wir öffnen aber umsichtig dafür
jeden tag meine damen und herren mich
freut sehr dass inzwischen rund fünf
prozent der menschen in deutschland eine
erste impfung erhalten haben und knapp
drei prozent haben beide impfdosen
erhalten und was mich auch sehr freuen
das in den altersgruppen in denen
geimpft wird auch die inzidenz deutlich
zurückgehen also besonders bei den über
80-jährigen die zahl der
intensivpatienten geht momentan nur noch
langsam zurück und auch die zahl der
todesfälle geht langsam zurück das sind
gute entwicklungen aber das sind leider
nur ist daher nur die eine seite der
medaille
auf der anderen seite sehen wir nach wie
vor zu viele todesfälle sind täglich
mehrere hundert die an das robert koch
institut übermittelt werden und wir
sehen dass die in tendenzen bei den
unter 80-jährigen seit etwa zwei wochen
wieder ansteigen die bundesweite 7 tages
inzidenz schwankt seit wochen um die 60
auch sie steigt tendenziell wieder an
das meine damen und herren sind auch
signal einer trendumkehr gleichzeitig
breiten sich die noch anstecken darin
saß kopf zwei varianten von woche zu
woche weiter aus und dies trifft vor
allem auf die besorgniserregende
variante b 11 7 zu wer zu erst in
großbritannien entdeckt wurde
vor vier wochen hat die b 11 7 noch
einen anteil von etwa sechs prozent an
allen untersuchten proben vor zwei
wochen etwas über 20 prozent und in der
letzten woche sind es schon mehr als 40
prozent auch der anteil von b 13 51 das
ist die variante die zunächst in
südafrika nachgewiesen wurde ist
angestiegen wenn auch auf einem deutlich
geringerem niveau
da liegen wir zurzeit bei einem anteil
von etwa 1 prozent an allen untersuchten
proben
sie finden diese daten alle in dem
entsprechenden bericht auf der webseite
des robert koch- institut unter
www.rki.de
es ist absehbar dass bei 117 bald die
vorherrschende variante in deutschland
sein wird
und dann meine damen und herren wird es
noch schwieriger das virus im zaum zu
halten denn bei 117 ist noch
ansteckender und noch gefährlicher
und zwar in allen altersgruppen das
bedeutet dass sie innerhalb kurzer zeit
noch mehr menschen anstecken als sonst
noch viele menschen schwer erkranken
können um die verbreitung neuer
virusvarianten besser zu überblicken und
deren effekt auf unsere gesundheit
besser zu verstehen wird ja im
robert-koch-institut die sogenannte
integrierte molekulare surveillance
ausgebaut
dank dieser können wir zum beispiel
genomsequenzen von laboren aus ganz
deutschland zusammen mit
epidemiologischen daten aus den
gesundheitsämtern integriert analysieren
und auswerten
dafür benötigen wir von den sequenzieren
labore die sogenannte gms die diese
erhalten die labore wenn sie die
sequenzen im deutschen elektronischen
sequenzdaten update hochladen
diese idee muss über die labor meldung
mit dem ist im deutschen elektronischen
meldung und informationssystem für den
infektionsschutz an die gesundheitsämter
gemeldet werden denn nur dann können die
fälle die über die miss gemeldet werden
mit den jeweiligen genomsequenzen die
oper des übermittelt werden verknüpft
werden und dass das ist die grundlage
der integrierten molekularen zu valens
und die voraussetzung für eine fundierte
einschätzung der auswirkungen der
varianten auf die gesundheit
demis soll das bisherige meldesystem
modernisieren es ist das meldesystem der
zukunft dank dem es wird das deutsche
meldesystem für alle beteiligten
praktischer es bildet das panini
geschehen umfassender und zeitnahe ab
und es ermöglicht uns dadurch schneller
und zielgerichteter zu reagieren
das lka hat schon vor der pandemie
begonnen es auszubauen und während der
pandemie wurde im juni 2020 die erste
ausbaustufe von demis erfolgreich in
betrieb genommen und seitdem stetig
weiterentwickelt
das besondere an dem es ist dass
informationen sicher und schnell
elektronisch ausgetauscht werden
und das über die gesamte meldekette also
von den laboren zu den gesundheitsämtern
zu den landesstellen bis hin zum
robert-koch-institut vor der einführung
von dem es war es so dass es auf der
ersten ebene also zwischen labor und
gesundheitsämtern teilweise noch faxe
gab
das war umständlich und aufwendig meinen
damen und herren und dass das ist jetzt
vorbei
durch die elektronische meldung liegen
die informationen schneller vor
maßnahmen können schneller umgesetzt
werden die daten können leichter
ausgetauscht werden zwischen allen
akteuren und so kann man auch größere
ausbrüche schneller untersuchen
inzwischen sind alle gesundheitsämter in
deutschland an dem s angebunden
auch mehr als 350 labore melden aktive
bei dem es dem es oft jetzt nach und
nach weiter zu zentralen digitalen
plattform für den öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst ausgebautes soll noch
weiter akteure angebunden werden zb die
arztpraxen
ebenso soll noch daten zwischen
gesundheitsämtern zukünftig elektronisch
ausgetauscht werden
und einiges mehr meine damen und herren
unser gemeinsames ziel ist ja weiterhin
ein frühling mit möglichst wenig
neuerkrankungen und mit möglichst wenig
schweren krankheitsverläufen und
todesfällen und das können wir erreichen
und ich wiederhole mich ja gerne das
liegt an uns das liegt an jedem
einzelnen maßnahmen wie kontakt
reduktion und die hotel regeln
sie wirken und sie wirken auch gegen die
besorgniserregenden varianten aber
natürlich nur wenn wir sie konsequent
umsetzen
nach allem was wir wissen wird auch die
impfstoffe gegen diese besorgnis
erregenden varianten alle impfstoffe die
zurzeit in deutschland zur verfügung
stehen schützen sehr gut vor einer
erkrankung durch b 11 7 auch erste
aufbruch untersuchungen zeigen dass die
geimpften wenn überhaupt nur leichte
symptome bekommen und die impfstoffe
schützen auch vor schweren erkrankungen
durch die anderen virusvarianten deshalb
wir jede woche meine große bitte wenn
sie einen impfstoff angeboten bekommen
lassen sie sich bitte impfen
die impfstoffe sind zugelassen sie sind
sicher und wirksam
das trifft auf alle in deutschland
zugelassenen impfstoffe zu übrigens
zeigen neuere studien zum astra weniger
impfstoff dass eine hohe schutzwirkung
auch bei über 65-jährigen besteht und
dass sich diese nicht wesentlich von der
hohen schutzwirkung der m rna impfstoff
unterscheidet die impfstoffe und alle
die sich impfen lassen weist uns den weg
aus dieser pandemie
danke dafür
ja meine damen und herren zu guten
morgen ich will gerne ort etwa stellt
unternehmen aus sicht eines
landesministers in diesem fall kommt aus
nordrhein westfalen dem bundesland wo ja
fast vierter jeder vierte mensch der in
unserem land lebt geimpft werden muss
wie sieht die im klare heute und für die
nächsten wochen diese überschauen können
aus die erste feststellung ist ja haben
wir ja auch wenn viele andere
bundesländer unserer altenheim als
allererstes serie der polit oben geimpft
das sind wir bei uns schon seit 14 tagen
fertig die sind alle zweimal geimpft
um nur ein beispiel zu nennen wir haben
in nordrhein westfalen ab 200.000
menschen die in stationären
pflegeeinrichtungen leben
wir hatten am 23 dezember in diesen
pflegeeinrichtungen 5000 infizierte
menschen und wir haben jetzt deutlich
unter 500 infizierte menschen und man
wird mir berichtet man auch dass selbst
die krankheitsverläufe die wir jetzt
noch haben so flach sind dass sie in der
regel nicht einfach ins krankenhaus muss
zweiter also die sache dass wir gesagt
haben wir ebenfalls allererstes die
stationäre pflege war auf jeden fall
eine richtige entscheidung und ich bin
auch davon überzeugt dass sie leben
gerettet hat er die wahrheit ist auch
dass die von den 12.000 toten die wir in
nordrhein westfalen haben
fast jeder zweite in einer stationären
pflegeeinrichtung gelebt hat zweiter
punkt ist
ja zurzeit im wesentlichen an impfstoff
sonntag und astra ziel
der blondschopf wird bei uns in
nordrhein-westfalen ausschließlich in
ins zentrum verimpft das hängt auch mit
seiner beschaffenheit zusammen und seine
ansprüche die er an seinen transport
stellt wir impfen zurzeit damit jeden
tag hunderttausend menschen jede woche
100.000 menschen die über 80 jahre alt
sind
sie haben in nordrhein-westfalen 1,2
millionen menschen die über 80 sind
200.000 haben wir in den altenheimen
geimpft wenn die meisten menschen immer
allerhand leben sind ja über 80 wir
haben vergeben über unser termin system
830.000 impftermine alle haben an erst
im stechen und ein zweiter termin und
wie es jede woche in den impfzentren
100.000 erstimpfungen 70.000 zweiten
empfohlen und ab mit zwei wochen ist es
da 100.000 erstimpfungen 100.000 zweite
gezwungen
das ist erstmal das programm für den
märz wo wir ja die impfstoff lieferung
einigermaßen einschätzen können bei
astrazeneca ist es so dass es schon wahr
ist dass wir vor allem in der letzten
woche und auch in der vorletzten woche
eine gewisse zurückhaltung bei diesen
stoff schlicht und ergreifend gehabt
haben
das bessert sich zurzeit enorm
also die aufklärungsarbeit findet hat
auch in diesem bereich gefruchtet
und wir haben jetzt sehr große
berufsgruppen im grunde in diese impfung
genommen für diesen impfstoff es ist in
nordrhein westfalen so dass wir davon in
den wochen jetzt märz noch rund eine
millionen impfungen in die arme der
leute bringen müssen
wir haben 130 tausend beschäftigte in
arztpraxen die alle jetzt ein ins geburt
bekommen angebot bekommen haben oder
bekommen
wir impfen aussuchen durch teams die
eingliederungshilfe das sind in
nordrhein-westfalen 150.000 menschen in
den werkstätten sind bei uns oft sehr
große einrichtungen wo man eben auch vor
sehr speziellen impfen kann wir haben
dann natürlich die lehrer die erzieher
die förderschulen
das sind bei uns auch noch mal so
300.000 leute und dann kommen eben
berater die teile der polizei und so
weiter dazu und das machen wir so dass
wir das zum teil über impfzentrum machen
zum teil auch sucht machen so das muss
man sagen wir haben da noch eine große
baustelle vor der brust den finde ich
schwierig zu organisieren ist nämlich
die chronisch kranke sie wissen als land
nicht mehr chronisch krank ist und wir
haben bei uns ist jetzt abgenagt mit der
kassenärztlichen vereinigung dass die
hausärzte nach diesen codierungen ihre
patientenakten durchschauen und wir dann
wirkliche der letzten märzwoche auch mit
der impfung in diesem bereich anfangen
können
wir werden sie dann aber über
hausarztpraxen machen wo da will ich
auch noch mal ein beispiel sagen dann
immer gesagt warum nicht jetzt schon
stärker in hausarztpraxen
wir haben wir nordrhein-westfalen 11.000
hausarztpraxen wenn ich jede aus praxis
sah er hat nur sage impfen wir bitte in
der woche hunderten menschen
das ist ja nicht viel dann brauche ich
dafür 1,1 millionen impfdosen und die
habe ich zurzeit schlicht und ergreifend
und deswegen sind natürlich impfungen
zurzeit er immer in etwas größeren
einheiten zu organisieren um eben dann
auch die die menge zu machen
wir werden in nrw eine sehr genaue
beobachtung des geschehens natürlich
auch vom ministerium aus machen dass wir
dann eben dieses ziel dass alles das was
wir haben ende des monats auch an
anderer cdk verimpft ist schlicht und
ergreifend erreichen
ich will ausdrücklich sagen dass er mir
gestern ein großer stein vom herzen
gefallen ist wo ich gehört habe dass
astrazeneca für über 65-jährige
eingesetzt werden darf vor allen dingen
deswegen
weil dieser in stoff gut ist weil er bei
der ersten impfung schon eine hohe
schutzwirkung macht aber jetzt für den
praktiker an landesminister die
umsetzung machen muss der ist natürlich
ein wunderbarer impfstoff weil er in der
lagerung und in der transport völlig
unkompliziert ist und sich natürlich
deswegen in besonderer art und weise
eignet ähnlich wie es vom
grippeimpfstoff kennen in hausarztpraxen
vereins zu werden und das wird uns
natürlich sehe ich eine große
flexibilität bringen die auch für die
menschen vorwiegend für behinderte
menschen ein segen ist danke schön danke
auch ihn kurz zum ablauf noch es kann
sein dass fragen die digital deutlich
vor 9 uhr gestellt wurden dass sich die
im system nicht mehr sehe also nicht die
jüngsten die sind da aber deutlich vor 9
uhr
ich kann jetzt schon sagen dass
vermutlich nicht alle fragen
drangekommen deswegen würde ich
diejenigen bitten die eine frage haben
sich möglichst zeitig zu melden dass ich
bisschen struktur einbringen kann und
ich beginne ein herrn linke wird eine
frage an herrn laumann und zwar zu dem
thema schnelltests herr spahn hatte
darauf hingewiesen dass das ab nächster
woche jetzt kostenlos das angebot geben
wird denn sie sagen wie das für nrw
aussehen wird also haben sie die
vorbereitung getroffen dass sie ab
nächster woche tatsächlich allen bürgern
diesen kostenlosen test anbieten und
können sie nochmal bitte sagen warum sie
das angebot eigentlich nicht früher
gemacht haben also es ist so dass wir
nicht letzter woche allen bürgern dieses
angebot machen können
wir haben eine situation dass wir in
nordrhein-westfalen gespräche geführt
haben
mit unseren vier tausend apotheken die
sind hoch interessiert in dieses
geschehen sich aufzustellen
wir werden sicherstellen dass unsere
apotheken dass auch außerhalb der
apotheke machen dürfen
weil die meisten apotheken baulich nicht
sich für massen testen
wir haben in vielen regionen
prix wartet des zentren wo man sich
heute testen lassen kann für 30 euro die
werden ab montag alle vor der situation
stehen dass die menschen sagen werden
ich zeige ja keine 30 euro mehr wenn es
auf der anderen seite kostenlose
testungen gibt die werden voll in dieses
geschäft einsteigen und es dann halt in
größeren zahlen machen
bei uns wird es so kommen dass die
kreise dann weitere anbieter in ihren
kreisen bestimmen können und selber
entscheiden ob sie dann auch noch
weitere kommunale ins zentrum machen
es gibt sehr viele anbieter auch von
großen bekannten ketten aus dem
drogenbereich die haben wir auch in
allen städten in den dörfern haben wir
die apotheken so dass ich sicher bin
dass wir diese struktur ganz schnell
aufgestellt kriegt wenn sie jetzt sagen
warum habt ihr das nicht eher
aufgebraucht ist ganz einfache sache für
alle menschen die sich bei uns testen
lassen wollten waren die kapazitäten da
alle arztpraxen haben getestet
alle kommunen haben wenn sie größere
flächen kreise mehrere kommunale
testzentren unterhalten und alle
apotheken oder nicht alle will ich nicht
sagen aber die meisten apotheken haben
ebenfalls die proteste angeboten so dass
es überhaupt keine briefe gar keine
proteste aus der bevölkerung kam was
diese frage angeht dass die struktur
natürlich größer werden muss wenn so
etwas kostenlos angeboten wird ist ja
völlig klar
und das ist ja auch jetzt bei bestimmten
öffnung strategien eine rolle spielt das
ja noch stärker machen das heißt diese
möglichkeiten müssten lehrer werden wir
werden morgen nachmittag im kabinett
festlegen wie wir das für den bereich
kita und schule organisieren auch da ist
es so dass alle lehrerinnen und lehrer
und erzieherinnen jetzt hier in
nordrhein westfalen mittlerweile zweimal
in der woche über eine feste struktur
die wir dafür geschaffen haben so seit
längerer zeit getestet wird wenn sie es
wollen
es hat kein zwang kann ich nur sagen von
diese freiwilligen angebot macht etwa
ein drittel des personals was die dass
andere kunden haben überhaupt gebrauchen
dann komme ich zu frau berheide micro
nicht genau
ich wollte noch mal nachfragen auch zu
dem thema schnell testieren wir sparen
mit einem momentan auch schon weiter
gedacht in form von digitalen zeugnissen
dass man zb der schnelltest der in einer
arztpraxis in der regel gemacht wird mit
einem qr code oder ähnlicher weise
dieses geld wird dass man das in einer
wie auch immer gearteten öfteren hat
sodass man war dass sein digitales
zeugnis dass man negativ ist dabei hat
oder oder auch positive test angemeldet
werden wir sehen da ihre planung
momentan aus also zum ersten zum positiv
testung in einer solchen in einem
solchen testzentrum den kommunen
beauftragt mich natürlich ans lka auch
gemeldet wir müssen jetzt schauen wie
sich die zahlen und die meldung dadurch
entwickeln weil ja empfohlen ist und
ausdrücklich auch möglich gemacht werden
wird in allen von den öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst beauftragten
testzentren und stationen dass der pcr
test der labortest direkt vor ort dann
auch abgenommen werden kann um dann eben
die bestätigungs testung zu machen das
ist wichtig dass die erfolgt und dann
tatsächlich zu sehen ob es auch richtig
positiv ist und nicht falsch positiv im
ergebnis was die frage angeht was die
frage der digitalisierung angeht ist es
so also ich finde ja wenn ich mir die
debatte der auch anschauen der letzten
zwei drei wochen
ich finde wir sollten doch einfach
gemeinsam positiv wahrnehmen was da vor
ort alles pragmatisch kreativ agil
innovativ schon längst entstanden ist es
gibt doch alles also die meisten
testzentrums anbieter die ich erlebe
haben doch digitale möglichkeiten auch
das testergebnis zu dokumentieren
manche machen es noch schriftlich das
stimmt viele machen es auch digital und
entsprechend kann es dann kann es dann
eben auch vorgezeigt werden wir haben ja
auch heute schon erfordernisse wer
einreisen
aus einem risikogebiet muss stand heute
ein negatives testergebnis zeigen es ist
ja nicht so dass so zu sein da der
rahmen auch nicht schon für gesetzt wäre
wenn die frage ist ob es ein
bundeseinheitlicher app vom bund
betrieben
die erfahrung ist ja nicht dass das per
se mit allen den dingen die ein bunt
übrigens bis hin zum vergaberecht weil
es gibt ja viele anbieter ich kenne sich
einfach sagen in einem bereich wo ich
schon ganz viele anbieter gibt
entwickelt der bund noch was eigenes das
geht nicht das ist das und es wird auch
dauern also setzen wir doch da auch auf
die innovationskraft der anbieter die
ich jeden tag sehe also es wird auch
glaube ich bei den selbsttests sich
fleck bin ich auch zu kreativ in meinen
gedanken weiß ich nicht aber es wird
doch so sein irgendwann das vor dem
restaurantbesuch dann eine stelle ist
also ist nunmal so gedacht eine stelle
ist vor dem restaurant da wird
vielleicht das erste getränk genommen in
der kleingruppe dass diese zeitweise
bestellt so dass da nicht eine riesen
pumpe ist tisch 15 5 leute kommt um
19.15 hat vielleicht draußen ein kleines
zelt aufgebaut macht den selbsttest
unter aufsicht gericht dabei ein getränk
geht dann rein
es ist das wird doch das muss doch nicht
alles der bund oder auch nicht mal die
länder und detail regeln das wird sich
doch ergeben wenn theater wissen sie
können wieder öffnen unter bestimmten
bedingungen und dann noch nicht voll
besetzt es werden ja nicht gleich 100
prozent der plätze besetzt wird und die
hygiene konzepte gelten ja weiter dann
werden die sich da bin ich sehr sicher
wenn wir ihnen sagen ihr könnt dann
beginnen wenn die die abläufe sozusagen
vor dem theater oder im theater so
überlegen oder im kino oder wo auch
immer dass das am ende einfach
selbstverständlicher bestandteil der
prozedur wird und da bin ich wirklich
vielleicht ja da bin ich einfach
wirklich optimistisch dass der
innovation kreativität pragmatismus vor
ort am ende immer jede idee die wir im
bundesministerium haben vielleicht noch
ein stück übertrifft
herr professor bieler hat in einer
schaltkonferenz mit chefärzten gesagt
ist ein tabu dass migranten bei den
intensivpatienten stark
überrepräsentiert sind daraus ergeben
sich zwei fragen einerseits warum können
fakten ein tabu sein und welche
konsequenz zieht aus diesen tatbestand
die politik also es handelt sich um ein
persönliches gespräch an informellen
austausch bei dem wir verschiedene dinge
überlegt haben aber keine endgültigen
feststellung gemacht haben es liegen
solche daten nicht vor es liegen solche
daten im robert-koch-institut nicht vor
paragraf 11 des infektionsschutzgesetzes
werden diese daten nicht erfasst es ging
bei dem gespräch um erzählung berichte
von einzelnen chefärzten aus drei
verschiedenen uni kliniken in denen zu
dem zeitpunkt diese zahlen genannt
wurden
ich kann nur hinzufügen wenn die frage
ist ich meine wir machen aufklärungs und
informationsarbeit in allen
bevölkerungsgruppen in vielen vielen
sprachen viele der aufklärungsarbeit
werden viele hier ich selbst übrigens
auch nicht gar nicht wahrnehmen in den
social media in den sozialen medien weil
sie zielgerichtet ob es berufsgruppen
sind ob es bestimmte bestimmte
zugehörigkeiten zu anderen gruppen sind
ob es altersgruppen sind wir machen ja
zielgerichtet für die unterschiedlichen
adressaten in unterschiedlicher sprache
in unterschiedlichen herangehen
informationen das ist doch die einzige
der einzige weg dass wir alle
bestmöglich darüber informieren in jedem
bereich des übrigen herausforderungen
die ist gar nicht neu deswegen verstehe
ich auch den begriff des tabus nicht
dass wir schon in vielen ländern
beschrieben selbst das amerikanische sie
hat sich schon mit der frage beschäftigt
wie wichtig es ist alle
bevölkerungsteile auch tatsächlich zu
erreichen und genau das beschäftigt uns
natürlich auch genau diese beiden fragen
scheinen mehr kollegen gehabt zu haben
ich sehe damit die fragen online von
kollegin hahn von ard-aktuell und von
dem kollegen rising von press aufbauen
antwortet wenn sie das anders sehen
geben sie mit digital einen hinweis und
dann bin ich beim kollegen rechts hinten
in der mitte am sonntag welt fernsehen
herr minister sparen es ist nun mal so
dass inzwischen ja auch die hausärzte
immer mehr die verantwortung genommen
werden wir hören jetzt auch erste
berichte dass er nicht ganz klar ist wie
das immer umgesetzt werden soll jetzt
haben große unternehmen sich auch zu
wort gemeldet mit teilweise
zehntausenden hunderttausenden
mitarbeitern und angeboten sie könnten
das auch über die belegärzte theoretisch
abwickeln da gibt es erfahrungen auch
mit grippe impfungen wie sind da die
überlegungen des gesundheitsministeriums
um vielleicht dann dadurch noch einmal
mehr tempo auch gewinnen zu können ist
ein sehr wichtiger punkt die
betriebsärztin und ärzte waren von
anfang an auch in unseren beratungen mit
den gesundheitsministern der länder
fester bestandteil aller überlegungen
die frage ist wann ist der richtige
zeitpunkt weil sie natürlich eine
priorisierung wenn sie die erste gruppe
nehmen über 80-jährige gesundheitswesen
also da übrigens in den krankenhäusern
haben ja auch betriebs erst sozusagen
und alle auch mitgemacht zweite
priorisierung gruppe in der wir jetzt
sind
impfen übrigens bei den polizeien bei
der bundespolizei wird so sein werden
auch die betriebsärzte mit impfen also
da wo es sozusagen passt auf die
jeweilige gruppe werden sie auch mit
eingebunden aber richtig gut auch von
der logik der ja immer noch notwendigen
priorisierung also ich bin führe ich
habe das mal genannt prinzipien geleitet
hat pragmatismus bin sehr dafür dass man
schon auch dramatisch vorgeht und nicht
das zu starr macht aber schon die
grundsätze der priorisierung ein held
weil wir natürlich jemand 40 jährigen
mit vorerkrankungen der jeden tag in
sorge ist und gerne geimpft werden
möchte und jetzt auch dran wäre schon
gut erklären müssen warum wir jetzt in
betrieben auch 30-jährige kerngesunde
impfen und die nicht in einem risiko
beruf sind und deswegen ist sind die
betriebsärzte logischer nächster schritt
so zu sagen wenn wir den menschen mit
vorerkrankungen haben ein angebot machen
können bei den eltern etwas weiter sind
werden wir auch gerade in den großen
betrieben natürlich die
betriebsärztlichen strukturen und auch
die die logistik die er dann geleistet
werden kann
sind unternehmen meisten unternehmen
haben ein hohes interesse daran dass
ihre beschäftigten schnell geimpft sind
die werden das sehr gut organisieren
werden wir die mit einbinde wir haben
schon erste gespräche mit der ddr
geführt das muss ja irgendwie auch
koordiniert der ansprechpartner da sein
das klassisch natürlich die arbeitgeber
seien bda und mit den verbänden der
betriebsärzte auf verschiedenen ebenen
noch ich werde da noch einige runden
machen um eben diesen nächsten schritt
vorzubereiten
also jetzt die arztpraxen das macht sinn
weil jetzt kommen die gruppen dran die
man auch gut sehr gut den arztpraxen
dann erreichen kann und die
impfstoffmenge nimmt entsprechend zu und
nächster schritt und natürlich ist er
auch in vorbereitung sind dann die
betriebsärztin betriebsärzte aber zu
diesem zeitpunkt der notwendigkeit von
priorisierung aus meiner sicht eben noch
nicht noch nicht nachvollziehen
nachfragen dazu wenn sie sagen das ist
ein logischer schritt wann wäre dass
dann möglicherweise weit den logischen
schritt keine hin beschreiben wenn ich
von den herstellern bis ende des zweiten
quartals alle lieferdaten schon aber das
habe ich haben wir noch nicht also
müssen wir wissen welche menge kommt ich
weiß zum beispiel nur mir ein beispiel
zu geben
ich weiß ja von contec-x kommen im
zweiten quartal 40 millionen dosen
wenn wir jetzt auch die ersten gespräche
über die zahlen für den april
da werden wir am montag mit dem
gesundheitsminister noch darüber reden
können
aber ich habe noch nicht die zahlen bis
ende juni rund 40 millionen kann sich
auf drei monate ja ganz unterschiedlich
verteilen so und dann in dem moment wo
wir besser die mengen einschätzen können
im zweiten quartal kann ich ihnen den
zeitpunkt ich würde stand heute sagen er
im zweiten quartal aber in dann erst
konkret men waren wir da auch die
betriebsärzte einbeziehen und es hängt
einfach von der menge des zur verfügung
stehenden impfstoffs ab der kollege
buchsteiner von pioneer fragt wie genau
arbeitet die task force für test
logistik waren nimmt der bund die
beschaffung nicht zentral
also die es übrigens wichtig es geht um
test logistik für selbsttests um das
noch mal zu adressieren bei den
schnelltest gibt es eingespielte gute
wege jeder der ein testzentrum betreibt
ob es der dak ist ob die apotheke ist
oder ob es der private anbieter ist oder
der öbb selbst jeder der ein testzentrum
betreibt weiß wir an schnelltests kommt
bei den selbst tests haben wir
festgestellt dass ich gerade beschrieben
habe das ist sozusagen wichtig ist dass
die schule die kita weiß wie die tests
zu ihr kommen zu ihr in der schule
kommen zur kita kommen und da haben wir
miteinander vereinbart jetzt am mittwoch
dass wir zwischen bund und ländern den
logistikern und den anbietern noch mal
noch mal schauen müssen sich aus den
gesprächen die ich jetzt einmal geführt
habe in den letzten zwei tagen
deutschland du weißt ja auch kollege
scheuer mit dem ich das jetzt zusammen
auch in abstimmung machte daraufhin zu
recht auf wissen doch logistik
weltmeister also wenn wir am ende wenn
ein land sagt ich habe hier in schulen
hat nrw weil sich viele schilder wären
einsatz hat land sagt wir haben wir
haben 5000 schulen oder 1000 schulen
jeder größe die adresse ist wie folgt
bitte liefert jede woche an diese
adresse in den nächsten drei monaten
soundsoviel selbsttests dann kriegt dass
jeder deutsche logistiker und hersteller
miteinander hin
das ist also nicht sehr keine
geheimwissenschaft das ist eigentlich
logistik und das ist genau das wo ich ja
sehe dass es die notwendigkeit gibt das
ein stück miteinander abzustimmen und
das ist auch das was ich gerade mit
kontaktbörse meinte die hersteller sind
doch bereit also wert gestern abend am
späteren habe ich noch ein zwei
telefonate dazu geführt 1 1 einen
hersteller gesagt sagen sie uns wann wir
wo was hingehen sollen
wir liefern so es ist nur die frage für
kitas und schulen ist ja eigentlich
originär mal der land das land zuständig
und ist auch nicht gesundheitswesen und
insofern müssen jetzt einfach
miteinander vereinbaren und das wären
wir in der tat vor
sprechen wäre das also wie das
organisiert wird aber das zu
organisieren
das ist von der logistik her und von dem
angebot her nach allem was die letzten
tage zeigen möglich also jeder also
werde die ministerpräsidenten
kontaktieren die kontakte herstellen und
dann glaube ich wird sich das auch
schnell einspielen können
die frage war noch wieso der bund die
wir schaffen nicht zentral in die hand
nimmt der die frage ist ja ob der bund
oder sie haben ja abgesichert wir
sichern bei den schnelltest zum beispiel
haben wir abgesichert 50 millionen
mindestens 50 millionen schnelltests pro
monat schnelltests jetzt erst abgerufen
werden im moment um die 10
das heißt also wir haben einen
rahmenvertrag geschlossen mit dem die
großen hersteller oder aller hersteller
im vertrag wenn sie wie machen die eine
planung die müssen ja weltweit planen
wie viel von unseren test dessen monat
produzieren gehen in den deutschen in
den europäischen markt wie viel in den
amerikanischen markt der welt geschäft
im moment welt darf nachfrage und die
sagen halt wenn ich weiß die
bundesrepublik deutschland steht im
zweifel dafür ein dass wir nicht diese
tests nicht verkauft kriege auf dem
markt wenn ich die aber für deutschland
ein planen im nächsten monat dann kaufte
deutschland die dann plane ich die 1 für
deutschland
aber dann können die die sie
normalerweise kaufen die auch kaufen aus
diesem kontingent
also der weg der bund kauft erst und
macht dann selbst die logistik den haben
wir in einer sehr schwierigen
herausfordernden lage an die ich auch
noch mal erinnern möchte angesichts
mancher diskussion bei den masken den
weg sind wir gegangen er war damals auch
notwendig weil es einen entscheidenden
unterschied zu jetzt gibt wir haben
jetzt eine sehr überschaubare anzahl von
herstellern im moment sieben zugelassen
oder in verkehr bringen und wir haben
die qualitätsprüfung sozusagen vor
marktzugang und menge schon verfügt bei
der fed vor zwölf monaten anders aber
die erfahrung allein daraus zeigt doch
dass es viel besser ist wenn die
einheiten die es auch brauchen auch
bestellen so lange wir sicherstellen
dass sie es bestellen können
das ist die ganze logik dahinter
an der stelle und das habe ich ja gerade
beschrieben ist möglich also wenn allein
ein hersteller mir gestern sagt ihr
könnte ab übernächster woche 20
millionen selbsttests pro woche zur
verfügung stellen bestehen nur jemand
sagen wo sie ihnen liefern soll
dann werden wir das jetzt organisieren
und ich mit den ländern sprechen dass
sie eben zu ändern da findet noch eine
nachfrage des kollegen strauß zur
saarbrücker zeitung auch zu der task
force ist deren einsatz ein erfahrung
gegen wie ersparen und wie erfolgt
konkret die abstimmung mit herrn steuer
also jede selbstverständliche
zusammenarbeit wir stimmen uns jeden tag
in unterschiedlichen task forces am ende
heißt es ja nichts anderes als
arbeitsgruppe und wir machen nichts
anderes jeden tag also mein ministerium
ob ich selbst oder meine kolleginnen und
kollegen wir sind jeden tag in
arbeitsgruppen mit anderen ministerien
mit ländern mit anderen beteiligten wenn
es um labortests geht gibt es eine ag
labore wo das lka dabei ist also wir
machen jeden tag nichts anderes als uns
abstimmen und koordinieren und das ist
das selbstverständlichste der welt und
die konkrete abstimmung mit herrn steuer
wie die erfolgt indem wir miteinander
sprechen
ich hätte würde eine frage zur causa
nüßlein
sie hatten glaube ich vergangene woche
hier angekündigt dass sie nochmal ins
archiv einsteigen wollten um zu gucken
was welche beteiligungen islam
maskenbild hatte sind ja schon
weitergekommen können wir uns da heute
schon ergebnisse verkünden und in dem
zusammenhang können sie sich eigentlich
erklären warum überhaupt offenbar
menschen wie herrn nüßlein gebraucht
wurden denn es hätte sich ja jeder beim
oben aufs verfahren ihres ministeriums
selber andienen können danke also wenn
ich erst was grundsätzlich jetzt noch
sagen darf auch ich meine das ist jetzt
zwölf monate er
wir haben ja auch damals häufig
telefoniert über diese frage wie schwer
es einfach war ganz zu beginn im märz
vor allem überhaupt an masken zu kommen
und angebote zu kommen
ich weiß noch weiß nicht wer deine
flieger der in amsterdam landen sollte
50 lkws war auf dem weg nach amsterdam
um die masken 14 und er ist nie gelandet
obwohl vertraglich zugesichert also das
war ja ein bild bestzeiten und
gleichzeitig gab es jeden tag also ich
weiß noch wie die uniklinik köln gesagt
hat wir haben ab nächster woche keine
masken mehr für unser personal macht was
die not war ziemlich groß und deswegen
gab es eben von unterschiedlichsten
seiten am ende viele angebote sie
wussten halt nur nie was sind jetzt die
verlässlichen angebote hier und wo kann
ich irgendwie darauf setzen dass dann
auch wirklich was was kommt und das war
ja die große herausforderung angebote
weitergeleitet wurden uns jeden tag von
landtags- bundestags- europaabgeordneten
kommunalpolitikern von bürgerinnen und
bürgern oder initiativ von denjenigen
den angebotenen selbst jeden tag ich
bekommen übrigens nur mal zu sagen
seit vor vorvorgestern jeden tag auch
angebote von selbst es jeden tag also es
ist alles wie vor 1200 kommen jeden tag
und sind offensichtlich da so das ist
die frage über den selbst es wissen war
wie gesagt es gibt sieben zugelassene
hersteller da haben wir ein
marktüberblick damals haben wir bei den
masken weil das ein ganz anderes
produkte ganz andere verfahren sind
konnten wir auch nicht haben er kein
marktüberblick sollen in dieser phase
sind wir natürlich jedem hinweis auf ein
potenzielles angebot nachgegangen das
open house verfahren dass sie
angesprochen übrigens das open house
verfahren macht unter zehn prozent
unserer beschaffung aus bei masten unter
zehn prozent
der größte teil waren direkt beschaffung
und die beschaffung über die
großunternehmen mit denen wir zusammen
dann starb sozusagen gebildet hatten
die china geschäft auch entsprechend
haben und produktion in deutschland
übrigens die wir an gereizt haben in
denen wir verträge abgeschlossen haben
und abnahmegarantien bis ende dieses
jahres gegeben haben und ein teil der
open house weniger als zehn prozent auch
um die größenordnung einfach mal zu
beschreiben des gesamten masken
beschaffenheit über open house
stattgefunden hat aber 99 prozent ist er
oder 99,9 aber jedenfalls so das ist
sozusagen die grundsatz aussehen zur
situation rund um die
staatsanwaltschaftlichen ermittlungen
habe ich am mittwoch im
gesundheitsausschuss berichtet sachlich
unseren stand der dinge das laufende
staatsanwaltschaftliche ermittlungen
sind sehen sie nach dass ich dazu jetzt
ihren detail nichts nicht sagen kann wir
haben der staatsanwaltschaft aktiv
kooperation angeboten stellen alle
unterlagen zur verfügung
und ansonsten müssen da jetzt einfach
die ermittlungen entsprechend laufen für
uns für mich waren keiner stelle
ersichtlich dass das ein dass das
potenziell unschuldsvermutung potenziell
irgendein anderer zusammenhang sein
könnte als bei allen anderen hinweisen
die uns auch erreicht haben ich habe
doch gut zehn fragen auf der liste
deswegen würde ich sie um knapp befragen
und knappe antworten bitten und bin ich
bei frau am ende dann doch den
widerspruch auflösen
da war ich vor genug bearbeitet worden
gesehen haben also zuerst einmal
deswegen habe ich das kleid auch bewusst
so formuliert und einfach auch die
erwartungen entsprechend einzuordnen ab
dem ersten märz wird der bund die kosten
übernehmen und setzt den rahmen bis hin
zur frage der kostenübernahme für die
pcr test viele länder haben angekündigt
und habe gestern noch gesehen rheinland
pfalz saarland bayern testet im übrigen
schon seit einiger zeit macht dieses
angebot ja selbst schon baden
württemberg dass sie an
der woche werden sehr umfänglich starten
können andere länder karl-josef hat
darauf hingewiesen haben in teilen gibt
es die strukturen schon in den kommunen
vor ort das hat eben auch immer was zu
tun sozusagen mit den kommunen mit den
strukturen die vor ort geschaffen wurden
in anderen bereichen wären sie noch
geschaffen aber wir sind glaube ich
beide zuversichtlich dass das schnell
gehen kann ist vielleicht nicht in
stunden aber doch dann in absehbarer
zeit und das angebot da ist die debatte
geht jetzt auch schon zweieinhalb wochen
mindestens
und insofern glaube ich ist es jetzt
einfach wichtig dass wir uns tun kommen
erstes tun es rechtlichen rahmen setzen
dass der bund die kosten übernimmt das
ist ja schon mal für alle wichtig damit
sie dann das was sie vor geplant haben
jetzt auch zügig umsetzen können und
dann wird sich zügig das angebot
entwickeln
und ja deswegen habe ich das klappt
bewusst gesagt und ich wäre dankbar wenn
was gemeinsam sozusagen auch einordnen
kommunizieren damit da nicht am 8 märz
schon alle denken jetzt ist es überall
schon alles verfügbar
das wird sich in den tagen darauf dann
entwickelt je nach lokaler gegebenheiten
schon gesagt ich meine rostock tübingen
böblingen zeigen ja auch schon und es
sind nur drei kommunen die immer genannt
werden also nach allem was ich sehe gibt
sich kommunen die schon strukturen haben
das ist passiert was die frage angeht es
zusammen ich hab mich sehr bewusst nicht
beteiligt an der frage wer ist jetzt an
was schuld ich könnte auch viele
geschichten erzählen aus den letzten
zwölf monaten
ich glaube einfach nur es hilft nicht es
nützt doch nichts
die bürger und bürger haben die
berechtigte erwartungen probleme lösen
dass wir uns abstimmen
dass wir nicht jeden tag in einem
interview sagen warum der andere eher
was hätte besser machen können sondern
wenn wir uns einander anrufen und uns
sagen ein problem liegt und das
versuchen gemeinsam zu lösen und das ist
der geist mit dem wir das mit den
gesundheitsministern untereinander
machen da bin ich auch sehr dankbar für
das das zusammen so gut gelingt und an
diesen grundsatz werde ich auch
weiterhin festhalten weil am ende unter
stress vertrauen unter diesem motto habe
ich häufig gesagt es wichtig in dieser
pandemie
zu arbeiten und vertrauen lebt davon
dass man probleme miteinander bespricht
und löst dann bin ich bei den kollegen
in der mitte haben um körper vom zdf
herr minister die hausärzte sollen jetzt
zügig in den prozess eingebunden werden
jetzt wird man aber auch da wieder
klagen von mangelnder organisation von
zu wenig informationen hätte das nicht
viel früher organisiert werden müssen
die idee ist ja nicht gestern geboren
worden oder also zuerst einmal die
kassenärztliche bundesvereinigung und
die kassenärztlichen vereinigungen sind
ja im regelmäßigen austausch mit den
ärztinnen und ärzten und mit uns also
ich habe ja keinen direkten
kommunikation zwar zu jedem hausarzt und
soeben hat sondern wir machen das über
die kassenärztlichen bundesvereinigung
die kassenärztlichen vereinigungen den
engen informationsaustausch haben
informationen zu den impfstoffen gibt es
seit ende dezember auf den seiten des
robert koch instituts das robert koch
institut ist ja eigentlich von seiner
ganzen logik wo der aufgabe her für die
fachöffentlichkeit da also das robert
koch institut ist eigentlich ein
institut von seiner gründung her für die
fachöffentlichkeit also insbesondere
auch für ärztinnen und ärzte und hat
jetzt natürlich in dieser pandemie eine
allgemeine breite öffentlichkeit zu
recht bekommen aber alle informationen
zu impfstoffen sind breit verfügbar und
den ärztinnen und ärzten auch zugänglich
es gibt auch informationsveranstaltungen
schulungsveranstaltungen viele angebote
auf verschiedenen ebenen zu den
impfstoffen die frage der organisation
sie haben ende eine von von regelungen
die zu treffen sind die impfverordnung
die wir gerade in der abstimmung haben
regelt zum beispiel erstmalig und das
ist ja auch wichtig die preise
die vergütung für das impfen in der
praxis wir sind in abstimmung gestern
und entscheide zu gehabt insofern mit
der ärzteschaft darüber wie die meldung
laufen ich sage dies meldet der melde-
umfang wird deutlich reduziert und die
bürokratie am zu machen für die
ärztinnen und ärzte in den praxen das
heißt es habe ich übrigens jetzt schon
vorneweg das natürlich wenn die
meldedaten bürokratie am gemacht werden
der umfang dessen was wir ihnen
statistisch liefern können dadurch auch
abnimmt
aber wenn ich ein
ein kompromiss finden muss zwischen
pragmatisch schnell und ganz viele daten
haben wir uns jetzt für pragmatisch
schnell entschieden auch das ist in
abstimmung mit den ärzten und der
ärzteschaft ich weiß dass gestern die kv
vorstände auch darüber informiert worden
sind von der kassenärztlichen
bundesvereinigung sodass wir bestmöglich
mit der erste schafft aber wie gesagt
ich wie kann nur über die verfasste
erster schafft über kassenärztliche
bundesvereinigung kassenärztliche
vereinigung und über die informationen
die wir beim robert-koch-institut oder
bei uns zur verfügung stellen da da
kommunizieren und wir werden sicher also
ich bin geht sofort bereit dazu und
jetzt wo sich sagen wenn wir es auch
machen noch meine townhall einfach
machen mit den ärzten und ärzten digital
im laufe des märz mit ihnen darüber
reden wie es dann wie es dann weiter
praktisch los geht rechtzeitig es wird
jetzt nicht in der verordnung kommen die
übermorgen umgesetzt werden muss zum
ernten in den praxen
sondern das wird jetzt auch rechtzeitig
miteinander gehen aber viel mehr muss
man ja schon gar nicht regeln vergütung
daten meldung wie kommen die impfstoff
wenn die praxis kennen die ärzte sie
bestellen meinetwegen plan ist im moment
sie bestellen am dienstag für die menge
die sie nächste woche gerne verhelfen
würden wahrscheinlich wird am anfang
deutlich mehr bestellt werden als wir
werden liefern können dann wird also
gibt es auch mechanismen dann wird
quotiert und es wird sortiert das ist
einigermaßen fair ankommt im land das
nicht alles zu denen kommt die zuerst
bestellen die möglicherweise aber dann
nicht regional fair verteilt sind für
all das gibt es mechanismen die heute
schon bei pneumokokken und anderen
impfstoffen angewandte angewendet werden
weil sie auch knapp sind und das kennen
die ärzte alles es wird sich alles in
den bahnen abspielen die idee jetzt
erkennen das heißt kurz hat zusatz das
heißt sie sind damit zufrieden wie das
bisher läuft mit den haushalt
ich bin jedenfalls mit den gesprächen
die ich führe mehrfach die woche und die
auch meine also ich persönlich aber auch
die kolleginnen kollegen in den
ministerien auf allen ebenen mit der
ärzteschaft mit den gesprächen und den
inhalten der gespräche dem fortschritt
der gespräche der konkretisierung der
gespräche zufrieden
die frage ob jetzt jeder dieser
information schon 100.000 arzt
immer angekommen ist weil sie ja sehen
müssen dass auf arzt ärzte jeden tag
ziemlich viele informationen per e mail
unter anderem kommt es dafür gar nicht
garantieren ich kann nur sagen dass wir
gute gespräche mit der ärzteschaft haben
julia oder nikolin links in der mitte
und dann herein schuster daher will er
eine eine frage werden was ja viele
befürchten durch das testen jetzt die
inzidenz steigen könnte weil viele leute
sich testen das die das von ihrem leben
getan hätten
gibt es da eine schätzung ab waren wir
da relativ schnell incidence bereiche
kommen die dann möglicherweise war die
notbremse auflösen würden wir sie
sprechen ein akt einen eine sache an die
die nicht trivial werden wird dass sie
haben recht es wird natürlich
schwieriger für uns das geschehen
einzuschätzen aber sie dürfen eines
nicht vergessen wir haben natürlich zum
einen die positive bestätigung durch die
pcr das heißt also dadurch werden wir
wir wissen jetzt schon dass es ein teil
von falsch positiven testergebnissen
gibt das ist kein mathematisch und auch
nach den daten die wir haben ist das so
das heißt also wir werden sicher eine
reihe von diesen fällen bestätigen
können nur als positiv und diese zahlen
sind natürlich dann ware zahlen wir
wissen auf der anderen seite noch gar
nicht genau wie viele menschen denn
überhaupt diese test annehmen werden
deshalb ist das unheimlich schwer
vorherzusagen
aber sie dürfen auch nicht vergessen
dass wir immer noch eine reihe von
anderen indikatoren haben also das habe
ich versucht oft zu klären dass wir ein
gesamtbild haben wenn sie in unseren
situationsbericht schauen da gibt es ja
viele indikatoren die wir haben sie
haben die belegung der intensivbetten
zum beispiel wir haben verschiedene
maßzahlen darum ist diese eine maßzahl
die wird für uns schwieriger zu bewerten
das ist schon wahr
aber wir haben noch genug andere
maßzahlen um einzuschätzen wie die
pandemie weiter verläuft darum ist
gerade natürlich die belegung der
intensivbetten ist ein wichtiger aspekt
und natürlich haben wir zudem ja auch
diese anderen werkzeuge die ich auch
schon glaube ich zwei mal vorgestellt
habe
diese balance daten über
atemwegsinfektion die wir ja auch seit
vielen jahren aufgehört haben wo wir
sehen ob die atemwegsinfektion steigen
oder nicht insgesamt sie schauen auch
nach anderen viren also alle diese
parameter die wir kennen
die sind dazu da uns klar zu machen wie
das infektionsgeschehen wirklich läuft
es ist auch noch nicht so vorherzusagen
wie zum beispiel die impfungen sich dann
aus wirken natürlich wird also die die
wir sehen jetzt ja schon sehr starke
wirkung der impfung bei den über
80-jährigen und es wird sich zeigen wer
getestet wird wie viele menschen schon
riefen menschen geimpft werden
das alles kommt zusammen darum möchte
ich da keine prognosen abgeben
sie müssen nur immer sich sicher sein
dass wir alle parameter die wir nach wie
vor in den händen haben immer noch
gegeneinander abwägen und auswerten die
kollegen links in der mitte also zuerst
einmal vielleicht mal kein josefa was
sagen zum bund länder zusammenarbeit
sozusagen aus landessicht was die
zusammenarbeit angeht kann ich für den
bereich den ich verantworte die
zusammenarbeit mit den kolleginnen und
kollegen in den ländern nur sagen dass
das eine sehr sehr gute vertrauliche
offene zusammenarbeit ist und dass wir
uns wenn was ist darüber sprechen es in
aller regel dann aber auch miteinander
lösen
gleichwohl wir natürlich auch merken
wenn der keine insel der
gesundheitsminister sozusagen
wir auch merken dass es insgesamt in
diesem wahljahr wir alle gemeinsam und
da kann ich ja nur für werben
in einer der schwersten wahrscheinlich
der schwersten zeit die bundesrepublik
deutschland die schwerste zeit die
bundesrepublik deutschland jemals hatte
die reihenfolge halt richtig haben das
ist das wichtigste ist pandemie
bekämpfung das ist das wichtig ist er
ist ein land in dem jetzt nach zwölf
monaten pandemie nach vielen wochen und
monaten lockdown einschränkungen
sozialen härten vieler land auch ein
stück wund gescheuert ist erleben wir ja
nerven blank liegen stress da ist
wahnsinnige sehnsucht nach normalität da
ist dass in einer solchen phase das
wichtigste doch ist dass wir die themen
lösen testen die frage wie es der
richtige weg die richtige balance von
umsicht und lockerungen und das auch so
machen dass die bürgerinnen und bürger
den berechtigten eindruck haben dass wir
das in der sache begründet alles machen
was wir machen und nicht aus anderen
gründen weil in diesem jahr noch ein
paar termine sind
das ist jedenfalls wäre meine mein
wunsch dass das miteinander gelingt das
gelingt da haben sie recht den letzten
tagen unterschiedlich gut was die frage
angeht der beratung wenn wir erleben im
moment das ist vielleicht eines der
themen von videokonferenzen das war ja
vorher die situation wenn interne
gespräche schon geld wie man das gefühl
manchmal hat es ist halt wie es ist
andersrum denke ich mir manchmal wenn
wenn das im zweifel dann kann man es
genauso gut live übertragen aber das ist
jetzt eigentlich aber eine interne
prozent eine besprechung tagen der
stelle weil dann würde ja tatsächlich
auch einfach deutlich wider gerungen
wird in der sache miteinander um eine
lösung zu finden und alles andere dass
ich halte mich zurück in solchen
belangen
also ich kann nur sagen wir haben ja da
einen festen mechanismus seit ende
februar letzten jahres haben wir jede
woche eine schalte der
gesundheitsminister in deutschland der
16 in den ländern plus jens wo alles das
gesprochen wird was anliegt weil die
auch eine sehr dynamische entwicklung
haben und sich oft die dinge ja auch
verändern
wir haben dann zusätzlich immer wenn zum
beispiel eine im verordnung an liegt das
ist derzeit der fall mehrere stunden
telefonkonferenz und videokonferenzen wo
sie uns austauschen und da ist es so
dass wirklich die wünsche der länder so
weit dass werbung geht auch schnell
umgesetzt werden um mutieren die auch in
der planung des bundes vernünftiger
einbezogen sind
ich glaube dass alle 16 kolleginnen und
kollegen sagen werden dass sich dieses
instrument sehr bewährt hat und täglich
es gibt aus meiner sicht nichts zu
kritisieren in dieser zusammenarbeit
was er war es ist erfolgen wo der
impfstoff noch knapper war wie ihr jetzt
ist der hat ja schon die situation
umgehen dass ein paar länder um die
impfstelle des lkws anzuführen nicht
sehr viel zugelegt haben und wo sich da
mal eine lieferung verzögert hat sind
die kolleginnen sehr nervös geworden und
dann sucht man natürlich sehr schön ist
doch klar
aber das lag daran dass die dann schon
fast 70 prozent ihres impfstoffs
verhilft halten da muss man ein bisschen
mit umgehen ich finde das ja jetzt noch
nicht mal in den konferenzen danach auf
das thema angeht schon eine gewisse
größe
herr schuster ersparen ich hatte sie vor
vier wochen nach den psychischen
erkrankungen als kollateralschaden
gefragt sagten damals noch keine
konkreten zahlen gibt es inzwischen
konkrete zahlen gibt es irgendwelche
konkreten schritte in dieser richtung
und als kurze nachfrage als nachweis
stadt meiner nachfrage zu der frage von
herrn rinke
ich habe wahrscheinlich was falsch
verstandener sparen sie sagten es gibt
mehr als genügend schnelltests dann sagt
er aber herr laumann im moment kann man
nicht jedem bürger einen anbieten wenn
sie das vielleicht noch werden könnten
vielen dank also zu den schnelltest das
eine ist sind die tests verfügbar und im
lager ja aber das reicht nicht sie
müssen ja vor ort umgesetzt werden so
und das braucht eine struktur und da hat
ja karl josef laumann zu recht darauf
hingewiesen die struktur ist wir kommen
beide aus nrw weekend unsere region in
einigen ländern in einigen landesteilen
und einigen kreisen und städten schon so
da glaube ich dass die schnelle werden
staaten können nächste woche in anderen
bereichen lernt jetzt entstehen
es reicht nicht den test einfach zu
haben also sozusagen ausreichend tests
sondern der nächste oder der zweite
struktur und die ist in grundzügen
überall schon da weil jeder testet ja
heute beim ausbruch schulen jeder testet
doch im gesundheitswesen vor ort also es
ist ja nicht so dass es keine strukturen
gebe die müssen jetzt sozusagen auf
diese neue herausforderung angepasst
werden
einige haben im lichte der diskussion
der letzten zweieinhalb wochen die
zweieinhalb wochen schon genutzt und
andere werden jetzt sicherlich schnell
in den irgendwie wenn ich nur kurz die
andere frage noch darf die psychischen
erkrankungen ist im übrigen wird der
professor wieder was zu sagen können
weil das ja bestandteil unseres
gesundheitsmonitorings ist wenn wir dazu
auch mehr sein können das thema ist halt
nur wenn sie auch abrechnungsdaten
nehmen wir zum beispiel einen indikator
zu sehen werden zusätzlich mehr
behandlungen abgerechnet wir machen die
kostenlose studie die wir ja seit zwölf
monaten auch mitfinanziert jede woche
veröffentlicht sozusagen
makro blick aufs land wie die
verfasstheit die einschätzung sind aber
das andere ist natürlich der
individuelle mögliche behandlungsbedarf
und den können wir tatsächlich jenseits
von umfragen dies ergibt erst abschätzen
im nachhinein wenn wir abrechnungsdaten
sehen das ist immer zeitverzögert und
entsprechendes monitoring haben oder
kann sicherlich herr professor wähler
auch noch anders zu sein
ja es gibt erste daten es gibt aber noch
keine wirklich überzeugenden daten es
gibt einige daten die darauf hinweisen
dass zum beispiel bei jugendlichen und
bei kindern ein höherer bedarf da ist
für besucher bei entsprechenden ärzten
aber wir haben noch keine wirklich
überzeugenden daten um das detailliert
beschreiben zu können
das muss ich ganz klar sagen aber das
wird natürlich im laufe der zeit genauso
transparent berichtet und analysiert wie
das für alle anderen kennzahlen des
gesundheitswesens der fall ist also jene
weiter zu den testen sagen ich glaube
nicht dass das material das problem ist
sondern wer macht es bekommen die
menschen her die schlicht und ergreifend
sache test durchführen
also werden sich jetzt in die schule
vorstellen wo 500 schüler sind dann
brauchen sie menschen die es machen und
ich glaube dass wir da was uns angeht
ganz gut aufgestellt sind
ich habe zu beginn der pandemie ein
freiwilligen register über die monate
aufgebaut in den viele tausend menschen
sind
das wird bei der kassenärztlichen
vereinigung bei der ärztekammer in
westfalen verwaltet die bereit sind und
in der pandemie zu unterstützen
natürlich auch gegen bezahlung es ist
kein ehrenamt aber die muss ja wenn du
so eine schule hast brauchst du leute
die es machen und zwar mehr wie ein
wenn du eine große verwaltung hat und
wir uns dass seine mitarbeiter in der
verwaltung jede woche zweimal getestet
werden
da musst du ein menschen haben der es
macht oder mehrere menschen haben die es
machen und da sehe ich eher den punkt
die so schnell zu mobilisieren dass das
in wenigen tagen steht und wir können
auf jeden fall
wehdem gemeinsam auch in den trägern
auch den schulen wendet euch an das
freiwilligen register nrw da gibt es
sehr viele krankenschwestern sehr viele
pfleger die bereits sind solche arbeiten
zu machen arzthelferin und so weiter im
budget sind ist unheimlich die leute ich
sage mal die noch nicht so lange in
rente sind und sich gut vorstellen
können noch mal wieder für einige monate
aktiv zu werden
wir machen noch drei knappe fragen und
bitte sie alle sorgen die zeit dabei im
blick zu haben frank busche dann die
kollegin links hinten und herr linke ja
danke das knüpft an das was herr laumann
gerade gesagt hat dazu noch mal die
nachfrage
das mag an mir liegen ich habe immer
noch nicht hundertprozentig verstanden
becher test wo zur anwendung kommen soll
sie am netz gesagt ersparen bei den
eigenen tests damit könnten schüler
getestet werden
das verstehe ich dann eben so dass die
sorge von herrn laumann dass man dafür
dritter abstellen muss nicht sein muss
also verstehe ich das richtig
schnelltests sind für die bürger in den
testzentren eigenen tests sind für
schulen und dann gegebenenfalls auch für
unternehmen für die das ja eine frage
ist müssen sie jemanden abstellen und
dann die zusatzfrage zu den unternehmen
wie stellen sie sich das vor wird quasi
einen anspruch gegen den arbeitgeber
geben dass man brot pro woche einen test
kriegt also zum ersten und letzten mal
unterschied die lehrerinnen und lehrer
in den schulen können ja schon weil
diese viel mehr als verschrieben auch
schon seit monaten glaube ich so vielen
monaten sich regelmäßig in manchen
ländern haben es gemacht sie können sich
testen lassen
andere länder haben gemacht es gibt
schulungen und dann kann man sich
morgens mit diesem weit in den rachen
oder weiter in die nase was ja nicht
angenehm ist wenn man es bei sich selbst
machen muss schon besonders nicht es
geht nur nachschulung aber dann können
sie es bei sich selbst machen das ist
eingespielt in der einen wie der anderen
facette tests mit schnelltests bei
schülerinnen und schüler denke ich das
ist aber am ende auch in der sender
sache wenn die allermeisten aber auf
selbst test setzen weil wenn sie eine
schule mit 500 oder 1000 ich war auf
eine schule mit dafür 1000 schüler 1000
schülerinnen und schülern
testen wollen zweimal die woche dann ist
das natürlich am schnellsten gemacht mit
selbsttests wo auch niemand in
schutzkleidung sich begeben muss und
anderes mehr sondern wo jeder bei sich
selbst im mundraum nasen raum das
entsprechend oder oder es wird ja dann
auch speicheltest anderes geben
das entsprechend oder diesen lutscher
test also meine zeit lang auf etwas
wissen was ich mal rutscht das wird
alles dann gehen und so wie ich den
eindruck habe es dass das was die für
schülerinnen und schüler eingesetzt
werden wird die selbsttests aber ich bin
voll bayern ist es ganz wichtig die
beiden kategorien immer wieder etwas
auseinander zu halten schnelltests
insbesondere auch da die machen vor
allem auch da sind erstens so einige
auch ab sich selbst nicht testen können
oder wollen weil sie unsicher sind
irgendwann mal sehen wie eine
bevölkerungsgruppe weise auf ob wegen
des alters oder wegen anderer
situationen die im zweifel sagen ihnen
ist auch lieber das ist jemand anders
macht und zum zweiten wo sie nachweis
brauchen allein schon beim reisen
brauchen sie in bestimmten bereichen ein
nachweis für für pflegeheim besuch oder
anderes mehr wo sie nachweis brauchen
macht es sinn das ist jemand drittes
macht ein testzentrum macht und das ist
das angebot was wir haben oder machen
wollen märz zur größenordnung wir sehen
in österreich und dänemark übrigens dass
die etwa 22 prozent der bevölkerung wenn
sich das mal eingespielt hat ich tippe
mal zu beginn wird es mehr sein aber
wenn sich eingespielt da zwei
zweieinhalb prozent der bevölkerung das
jeden tag nutzen
es werden auf deutschland bezogen
eineinhalb bis zwei millionen menschen
am tag das ist für mich zu schaffen in
der struktur schnelltests die
selbsttests eben in bestimmten settings
für die unternehmen ist dass wir am ende
eine entscheidung der unternehmen ob sie
eine struktur aufbauen sozusagen mit
schnelltests wo dritte gibt ja auch
externe dienstleister die das machen
können oder eigene geschulte leute das
machen oder ob sie was wahrscheinlich in
der perspektive also ich gespräch mit
den unternehmen zum beispiel die einen
sagen ich habe präsenz betrieb
produktionsstandort
produktionshalle maschinenbau da kann
ich im zweifel eine ecke frei machen
testen an wie der andere sagt ich bin
betrieb vor allem mit außendienst da
macht der selbsttest mehr sind ich bin
sehr zuversichtlich dass die unternehmen
und betriebe auf ihre individuelle
situation hin auch dort die richtige
lösung finden im rahmen auf einer
verpflichtung zum sich selbst auch
verpflichten das ist ja vor allem auch
unser ziel dass wir das als gemeinsame
nationale kraftanstrengung und begreifen
dass wir in allen bereichen in allen
lebenswelten ist der klassische
präventionspolitik lebenswelten betrieb
kita schule pflegeheim dass wir in den
bereichen zu regelmäßigen testung kommen
und dass alle beteiligten ohne dass
alles erzwungen werden muss idealerweise
eben mithelfen dass diese nationale
kraftanstrengung gelingt im übrigen
sehen wir das testen allein das problem
nicht löst österreich fragt jeden tag ob
wir impfdosen ausleihen können beides
pandemie geschehen ist wie es bin sehr
dafür dass wir testen wie in anderen
ländern aber testen alleine auch in
österreich nicht löst das programm
weiterhin darauf an auch die anderen
aspekte im blick zu haben und deswegen
waren wir uns mit unseren nachbarländern
auch das sind die gespräche die auf eu
ebene stattfindet geht nicht bilateral
aus meiner sicht aber ich bin nicht nur
einmal sagen muss man das gesamtbild
sehen testen ist wichtig aber es ist
nicht das einzige was notwendig ist
die kollegin links hinten rechts von
ihnen aus ersparen plant ihr ministerium
eine studie über den anteil von
patienten mit migrationshintergrund auf
intensivstationen wie es in
großbritannien der fall war und
vielleicht mögliche strukturelle
missstände herausfinden zu können wie
angehen zu können
also bisher ist es nicht nicht geplant
müssen ob das sinn machen kann vor allem
und miteinander zu lernen was besser
geht an der an der stelle
also nimmt also die frage war ja ist es
geplant aktuell nicht geplant
kurze frage italien und die eu haben ein
exportverbot für den italien
produzierten astra celica impfstoff für
australien erlassen ich hätte ganz gern
gewusst ob die bundesregierung ob sie an
ähnlichen export stoff exportverbot für
in deutschland produzierten impfstoff
lassen wollen weil es zweifel gibt ob es
tatsächlich er seine verpflichtungen
gegenüber der eu anhält
also zuerst einmal ist das ja eine
europäische regelung dass es die
entsprechende exportkontrolle sie
erstmal kein verbot sondern sie müssen
genehmigt werden
exportbeschränkungen kontrolle es nennen
wollen dass es die gibt auf europäischer
ebene geprüft werden das ist das normale
übliche verfahren tut da wird das auf
nationaler ebene aber es ist europäische
sozusagen regelungs geben
wir prüfen auch die hersteller in
deutschland sind ja auch gehalten uns
anzuzeigen
wir haben dazu den ablauf mit dem
wirtschaftsministerium dass er ins
berner für außenhandels fragen zuständig
ist ein paul-ehrlich-institut der sich
das gut eingespielt hat uns geht es vor
allem darum transparenz zu haben und
diese transparenz wird dann eben mit der
kommission geteilt die führt das
zusammen was die maßnahme jetzt in
italien angeht hatte ich tatsächlich
noch nicht die gelegenheit mich mit
meinem italienischen kollegen dazu
auszutauschen was der anlass jetzt für
diese maßnahme ist es ja so dass wir
natürlich großes interesse haben müssen
und im zweifel auch druck machen müssen
dass zugesagte lieferung eingehalten
werden und verlässlich eingehalten
werden
insbesondere dann wenn es offensichtlich
auch impfstoff gibt und gleichzeitig die
welt sehr verwoben ist miteinander und
gerade bei impfstoffproduktion und
vorprodukten und
die frage manchmal wechsel zwischen
kontingenten nur für die abfüllung
kontinenten zwischen kontinenten nur für
die abfüllung hin und her geflogen weil
es die absolut kapazitäten auf dem
eigenen kontinent nicht mehr gibt und
manchmal sozusagen verlässt etwas
deutschland oder europa aber manchmal
kommt auch was zurück und oder rein was
notwendig ist und ich finde wir müssen
genau bei jeder maßnahme schauen dass
wir zwar kurzfristig vielleicht ein
gewinn haben aber nicht auf mittel sicht
uns ganz die diese versorgungsketten bei
impfstoffen und allem was ein
vorprodukten notwendig ist in probleme
bringen so das kann ich so allgemein
formulieren für die konkrete situation
jetzt italien werde ich tatsächlich das
gespräch mit dem italienischen kollegen
noch mal suchen was jetzt genau der
anlass war dadurch die frage aber
nochmal präzisieren ich hatte gefragt
danach was sie machen wollen also in
italien hatte schon gemacht es geht ja
darum der in deutschland produzierte
hast weniger impfstoff auch exportiert
werden darf in deutschland wird so weit
ich den überblick habe kein impfstoff
von astrazeneca produziert das wurde und
wird zum teil abgefüllte kein geheimnis
der öffentliche wc in dessau abgefüllt
produziert wird dann noch nichts gibt
also überlegungen auch dort miteinander
miteinander zu kooperieren
also wir hatten jedenfalls bestand heute
nicht den anlass dazu
impfstofflieferungen nicht zu genehmigen
in andere teile außerhalb europas ich
würde so ein vorgehen aber immer auch
europäisch abstimmen wollen
das ist eine gemeinsame europäische
massnahme es ist eine gemeinsame
europäische einschätzung ja ob unsere
verträge bedient werden ausreichend oder
nicht im verhältnis zu dem was europa
verlässt
und insofern ist das aus meiner sicht
vor allem auch etwas was wir gemeinsam
europäisch abstimmen sollten abwägen
sollen
vielen dank ich bitte sie um verständnis
dass nicht alle fragen
dran kamen und sehen sie mir den
zeitlichen überzug nach damit sollte
kein exempel statuiert werden schönen
tag noch in vielen dank ihnen ein
[Musik]